police in Washington in Charlottesville
Virginia are bracing for protests and
counter protests this weekend on the
first anniversary of a notorious unite
the right rally violence during that
white supremacist gathering in
Charlottesville left one woman dead a
state of emergency is in effect there
and in other parts of Virginia this
weekend Margaret Brennan interviewed
Charlotte Bill's first african-american
mayor macaé Walker for Sunday's face the
nation with the benefit of hindsight now
I mean it this is a year later do you
think this community a year later has
healed absolutely not
not at all no because the the issues
were not the rally or just statues the
issue is in this deep-seated racism that
that we have here and that's the
challenge and that's a lot of work and
it takes commitment and while people
don't want all right white men and khaki
pants and polo shirts you know walking
through town and they want to make it
clear that they don't identify there
they have been very comfortable with
racism and how it plays the community
face the nation moderator and CBS News
senior foreign affairs correspondent
Margaret Brennan is with us from
Washington Margaret good morning good
morning so you have ties to
Charlottesville you attended the
University of Virginia how is the mayor
trying to fix some of these deep-rooted
issues in her city well you know the
mayor is very passionate and she says
focusing only on these rallies is
avoiding the real issues that are
plaguing that city including she says
low wages lack of housing and she argues
all of these divisions come down to
issues of Economic Opportunity you know
President Trump likes to point out that
african-american unemployment is at an
all-time low a jobless rate of just six
point six percent as of last month but
the mayor says she hasn't seen an
improvement in her community and she
holds the president personally
responsible for as she put it bringing
to light hate is she concerned about
anything that could happen in
Charlottesville this weekend to mark the
anniversary yes
no permit for a rally has been approved
but the state of Virginia priam
declared a state of emergency that's
really because authorities were harshly
criticized last year for allowing it to
escalate there have been lawsuits
there's been real backlash from social
media companies who have made it more
challenging for the unite the right
organizers to mobilize but they've
decided to bring that demonstration to
outside the White House on Sunday so
there's this is more than just the one
rally this is about fault line scale in
our country that have been exploited for
political gain and we are gonna talk
about those issues of identity politics
and divisions in America on Sunday show
with Virginia Democrat Tim Kaine and
Margaret you also talked with the mayor
about the issue of Confederate statues
can you tell us about the memorial in
Charlottesville now well you know even
with the first african-american mayor of
that city that Confederate memorial to
robert e lee is still standing
it was the flashpoint for last year's
rally but Virginia courts are still
debating about whether it's considered a
symbol of white supremacy or a war
memorial nationwide those 75 Confederate
memorials have been removed or renamed
since last year all right Margaret
Brennan thank you so much that interview
with Charlotte fields mayor is part of
an in-depth look at race in America this
Sunday on Face the Nation and as
Margaret just mentioned she will also
talk with Virginia Democratic senator
Tim Kaine Sunday right here on CBS